volvemos con la actualidad deportiva en
france 24 de la mano de nuestro colega
luis méndez luis bienvenido y empecemos
con las noticias de fútbol concretamente
de la copa américa femenina porque ya
terminó la tercera jornada del grupo a
un grupo que se complica y que dejó como
gran ganador a paraguay queso 3 puntos y
es colíder junto a colombia de la llave
aunque tiene un partido más pero para
conocer detalles de lo que fue el juego
de cierre entre chile y ecuador vamos a
la ciudad de cali con nuestra enviada
especial estefanía montero
saludos estefanía buena noche para usted
chile consigue sus primeros tres puntos
en el torneo con ello vuelve a retomar
su condición de favorita para esta copa
efectivamente la subcampeona actual de
este certamen se volvió a meter en la
pelea como diríamos acá chile logró tres
puntos importantísimos que además pone
en el grupo supremamente apretado un
grupo que tiene como líder a colombia
paraguay con seis puntos y que deja de
ecuador después de perder dos goles a
uno frente a chile precisamente con tres
puntos chile y ecuador quedan con tres
puntos y bolivia en el fondo psoe que no
ha sumado aún el partido un partido
disputado un partido con oportunidades
más del lado de las chilenas que lo
intentaron más que lo buscaron más y que
por ahí el minuto 40 después de
intentarlo muchas veces tras un tiro de
esquina llegó lo que para muchos de la
tribuna vimos como un gol olímpico pero
que finalmente terminó siendo gol de
camila sáez en el segundo tiempo las
ecuatorianas salieron con todo a buscar
el empate no lo consiguieron y por ahí
en esos despistes defensivos por ir a
buscar el ataque llegó el segundo tanto
de jenny acuña por parte de las chilenas
un minuto después les puedo decir
entraba martín aguirre quien se
convertiría en la anotadora del gol de
las ecuatorianas
ecuador lo intentó lo buscó hubo ciertas
polémicas en el arbitraje unas jugadas
por ahí en las que no se respetó la ley
de la ventaja para las ecuatorianas pero
al final las chilenas celebraron los
tres puntos bastante ecológico este
partido de estefanía y gracias por su
reporte